a killer is headed to prison for the
rest of his life thanks for staying with
us here at 4 30. I'm Denise Valdez and
I'm Vanessa Murphy This is a story the 8
news now investigators have been
following it started with a missing
person's case nearly three years ago and
ended in a tragic way
it's heartbreaking that the memories
is the terrible pain we had to tolerate
Cheryl Lynn beardall's son Achilles
facing his mother's killer in court
Wednesday Phillip O'Reilly offered no
apology Mr O'Reilly do you want to say
anything no you're wrong this is moments
before he received a sentence of life
without the possibility of parole
beerdahl's family giving O'Reilly a
send-off as he heads to prison her uncle
admitting thoughts of Revenge her mother
sharing the pain of losing a child what
gives a screaming mother light at the
very end of this dark tunnel
is that he will not get out
foreign
back in 2020 O'Reilly claimed beard all
picked up and left him in the kids then
the search for the mother of three
became a missing person's case O'Reilly
was arrested he was charged with murder
child abuse and sex crimes against
children it was revealed beardall
suffered long-term abuse by O'Reilly who
beat her with a dog leash with the
children present only knowing that they
have only seen her beaten to an inch of
her life and then be told that she left
them there with their abuser this is
beardle's Sister who the children now
live with O'Reilly tried to hire a hit
man from jail to kill her along with her
husband and two of the children who are
not biologically his once he knew he was
caught he agreed to a plea deal which
takes the death penalty off the table
part of me was surprised as he has put
him through a roller coaster since he
entered our life Jessica canutilla also
shearing a victim impact statement from
beardle's youngest Phillip killed my
Mommy Cheryl Lynn the five-year-old girl
is also O'Reilly's biological child I
want him to always stay in jail forever
so he can't hurt me anymore
part of that plea deal involved Philip
O'Reilly disclosing where he put
beardall's body as her family revealed
today in court he said he dismembered
her remains and disposed of them her
mother says she doesn't believe he even
told the truth about that Denise